here on the live stage at YouTube
presence at PAX Prime 2015 I'm Chris
waters for gamespot and i am here to
talk with some guys from Bungie about
one of the biggest releases this fall
destiny the taken King Luke mark thank
you guys for joining me here on stage
thanks for having us man dude it's uh
it's just a few weeks away the taken
king and you guys have been like teasing
stuff out over the past few weeks like
really ramping up to a pretty big
release we hope so I mean over the last
few weeks we've been revealing more
information and trying to get people
excited understand what the game's gonna
be about this fall and one of the things
it is going to be about is like a really
big new narrative push there's a huge
new story I I think I heard you guys say
that you know like this compared to when
destiny launched this has more sort of
story content more story missions it's a
beefier story experience yeah like
there's a brand new campaign right like
the taken king is here and and eat you
know he's got one thing in mind and
that's revenge for the death of his son
crota and you know we've invested a lot
of time and improving storytelling in
the taken king and you know there's we
got a bunch of you know set up real
actual cinematics and and you know we
really wanted to focus on the characters
in year two of destiny and we we've
taken some of the characters that people
really have really resonated with them
in the tower those characters that
you've been sort of working with the
last year buying gear from and and
brought them into the game more so like
Kate six he's one of the vanguard
mentors voiced by Nathan Fillion and
he's one of the primary characters in
the game now and so you'll be going on
missions and he's talking to you and
he's really funny right and this is a
thing we wanted to bring forward as some
of that humor and like in the in destiny
right now if you go stand next to Kate
six and you just listen to him he said
some stuff and one of the things he says
is take me with you and you're like wow
like he really wants to be out there
fighting with me this is awesome we
thought this character is so compelling
like we need to bring him and some of
the other characters into the game you
know you kind of get that sense the
little bit of it like a caged bird sense
from some of those vendors like man I
bet you have some stories to tell
tell me some well and that I mean that's
exactly it right like we haven't ever
communicated the backstory for these
characters or let you learn anything
about these characters who've had this
like otherwise like transactional
relationship with like i'm going to give
you Vanguard marks you're gonna give me
armor and now these guys are going to be
pushing you through missions a little
bit for also taking a bunch of notes
from the way that the game's been
evolving over the last year like
watching watching the team introduced
new characters like Eris and then verax
and Petra and getting to hear more
voices and characterful interactions and
in a game that that the premise of the
game is revenge like that is an
opportunity to be pretty pretty dark but
when you have a guy like Philly and he
can inject a bunch of humor into that
darkness yeah it's nice to have a little
bit of levity there when the whole fate
of humanity's on the line yeah I think
one of the things I you know sort of one
of the ways you know obviously the
cutscenes are like our lovely and like
really you like the thing you sort of
strive to see at the end of your quest
but you also want that quest to tell the
story when you're out in the field you
want you know the story to be
communicated to you while you're well
you know between shooting breaks and you
guys have done some of that with you
know it's ghosts and I think what's the
way that like you've talked about the
structure of the quests for taking king
being a little different being a little
bit more like exotic bounties in the
past can we get a little bit into sort
of how that structure is going to just
like really bolster the the narrative
experience yeah I mean there's two
things there that we can talk about the
first is the Easter to the ghost so we
brought an old north on board to voice
the ghost and he's doing an awesome job
but we want we wanted to find the ghost
voice a little bit differently this fall
with the sort of opt-in Laura this thing
that you have your little robot droid
sidekick like what can he tell you about
this cabal base you're looking at when
you're walking around it like he's got
all information so we added a new system
that's ghosts can well lets you sort of
opt-in if you want to explore the world
and find a little extra lore that's one
way that we've done it the other thing
that you're asking about the quest
system we overhauled the entirety of all
the destiny content into this thing that
we've just called quest ification and
that's basically I mean it like to talk
about quests like they're a new thing is
sort of embarrassing but what we're
trying to do is give players a clear
clear context for what they're doing and
why clear rewards for what they're going
to get it at the end of it and hope that
that helps give them some thrust into
the world versus the hey you finished
you finished a story campaign now find
your own fun which is I think sort of
what we bumped into a little
last fall with the release of last
year's game mm-hmm now you guys have
been over the course of this over the
course of year one so active with
hearing community responses in like
connecting with the game with the the
people's experience of how they you know
how they experience destiny what where
are their sort of blacks where their
opportunities for you guys to come in
and I think one of the interesting ways
you did that was for the raid for crota
you know that was a normal mode raid but
then you develop the hard mode rate as
sort of a reaction to how people were
taking on the normal mode is that is
that sort of the design philosophy going
forward or sort of when you tackle this
raid the Kings Hall Kings fall how are
you coming at it so what we did with
Kings fall was the raid team I haven't
learned a bunch of a bunch of great
lessons on crota that the time delta
between normal and heroic allowed us to
fix a bunch of bugs at this time
mechanically when we set up to build
Kings fall we built the hard mode
version first so we built all the hard
Mon mechanics we actually added new
mechanics for a bunch of the fights
we've got some other sort of new stuff
for the raids that we're not talking
about yet but uh and then what we did
after that was we scaled it back to
normal so that we have the hard mode
that we understand the mechanics for and
then a normal experience that again
meets those like really important trade
pillars of any motivated group of six
players can communicate cooperate and
get through the red mhm and you teased a
little something extra for the raid as
well just give just repeat the tease I
know you're not gonna tell me what it is
so we developed the card mode version of
the raid and then we scale it back to
normal we have a little bit more plan
for the raids this fall we're not
talking about them just yet alright cool
so let's talk about that hard mode and
the way that mechanics are brought into
it because I think some of the more
exciting fights in destiny are where
there are different mechanics that
subvert the way you normally play the
game and create a new strategic
challenge you guys it sounds like you're
doing a bunch of that also in the courts
of Oryx yeah let's talk a little bit
about that the court of works is this
place on the dread-nots the dread-nots
is the taking Kings capital ship and you
come across this this area and they're
these six statues and in kind of a
atrium like place and
what you can do with each of these
statues if you collect a certain ruined
you can use the ruin on the statue and
what will do is it will trigger a public
event and you know a rift in space-time
opens up and bosses start pouring out of
it and these bosses each one of them has
some kind of unique mechanic or you know
system that players that you know in
public are going to have to figure out
together I wouldn't say they're you know
the there as difficult as the raid but
they're sort of raid like and we really
excited about it because it gives the
opportunity for you know someone just
running through an area he's on a
mission maybe and he looks over and sees
someone someone's a boss and there's a
countdown if I get in there in the next
ten seconds I can I could participate in
this and help this guy out and you know
we have we have a bunch of bosses that
you can summon and there are different
tiers that you know eventually you get
access to and you get really really good
rewards for participating in it so we're
stoked about it one of the one of the
things about court that was really
important to us as we wanted a way for
there's so much to do on the dread-nots
it's unlike any place we've ever built
there's already a bunch of stuff to
explore and hunt down and find but we
wanted court of Orcs to also be this
thing that reached out to you and your
buddies as an opportunity like hey did
you get a rune while we were playing
let's go bang that out or you like slip
through the bubble and you see in the
distance when you walk in you see the
fight going on and you're like oh [ __ ]
let's get in on that it's already
happened yeah like Martin's think there
are three tiers and you'll find
different rooms for each and they get
they require more and more powerful gear
so it's also going to your progression
through quota bars is going to really
mirror your progression through the game
because you're not going to be able to
get to that higher tier unless you've
got that gear yep alright well let's
talk about gear for a second because one
of those sort of much debated topics is
uh exotics everybody loves chasing those
exotics yeah they are after them and you
know you're one exotics and year two
exotics like art you know those exotics
have people hunted down there they're
Hawk moons argali horns all that stuff
that going to be viable come the year
two or is that like you you're just
gonna give him some new stuff to chase
we have a bunch of new stuff to chase
right like the start of the taken king
is the beginning of year too and you
know Oryx the taken king is more
powerful he's on a ship that's millions
thousands of you
sold its full with loot and foot with
gear and and he's brought this taking
army with them and they're stronger so
you're going to have to find more
powerful gear in your to to really be at
the cutting edge but you know we do have
some things yeah there's a guy on the
shirt on the audience right now wearing
a shirt that says keep common gallon and
out what I'm hoping to see next year is
a shirt like this that says keep calm
and touch of malice like we've got new
powerful [ __ ] for people to check out
we're also bringing some of those some
of those weapons forward into year two
we're not bringing all of them forward
alright one of the new things for gear
hunters is at the artifact another slot
another thing this one's actually not
unlike I you know you guys when I was
watching the livestream you said it's
not cosmetic which actually made me
realize how much of the gear in destiny
is cosmetic and how much it just like
goes towards making you look and feel
like a badass but what why did you want
to like throw in a little extra thing
there the artifacts sort of what purpose
does that serve outside of other gear
here's role well in overhauling the
progression system with the new light
system we wanted all the slots to matter
we also really wanted the game to feel
more generous and you to actually get
way more loot when you're playing the
game want to lead into the fact that we
are a loot game in order to do stuff
like this we need to add extra slots of
the character what we did with the
artifacts lot was we took a particular
type of perk like orb generation for a
variety of different things and we
isolated that down into the artifacts
lot so that what you're doing when
you're hunting for artifacts is you're
looking at either the current subclass
you have equipped am i running the
defender Titan or the Sun breaker Titan
well that's going to influence if I want
the void grenade perk or the solar
grenade perk that triggers orbs or if
it's off of precision kills you're going
to be looking at your arsenal on going
like oh I have this arc precision kills
artifact against them needs my arc
sniper rifle it's just to allow more
customization tinkering that's another
one of our big things big things for a
year or two is in last year's game the
grind for power was so long man it was
it was a long quest to get into that
vault of da ya sometime we know that we
definitely heard that well what we're
interested in doing now is lessening
that vertical climb it's stretching it
out horizontally instead when I say
horizontal progression I mean getting
the right pair of boots that have the
exact talents and stats on them you're
getting that base power level much
easier to get into the activities that
you want to play but like that extra one
percent that final five percent of
efficacy that can take a little bit more
time because that ultimately doesn't
matter to a lot of people Amy but it
does matter to some real hardcore
players and those guys have like
sustained you guys in like a real
powerful way I think one of the
challenges for taking king that you guys
have is like how do you like you know
you create that stuff that's gonna like
really draw in the hardcore and like
allow them two distinct er entry but
then also create an opportunity that
makes it feel welcoming to people who
may be like you know I played it last
year but I kind of fell off or my
buddies have been playing it they've
been trying to get me in but I just
don't know like to bring in the new
audience as well with taking Kings so
how do you guys sort of balance that
yeah it's totally been a balancing act
since we started working on the project
but you know one of the things we've
done is we've introduced this new item
called the spark of light that anyone
who buys the taken King whether you know
you're buying the forty dollar upgrade
or you're buying the new $60 like all in
package the legendary edition gets this
item and as soon as you play the first
mission in the game you go to the tower
you talk to the postmaster and you'll
get this and what the spark of light
does it will automatically upgrade in
level 25 which is the starting level for
the takin you know the ticking king and
you get a new suit of armor and guns
ready to go to play you know alongside
your buddies so if your friends been
thinking about playing destiny and your
level 34 now is still perfect time for
them to come in because within 20
minutes they can be playing an activity
with you and they're right alongside you
doing whatever you guys are doing
obviously the crew over here is hype
here on the hush guys are real they're
real excited for our they just can't
wait to the level like that way my
dating without I'm so excited about this
you know you guys are giving the people
what they want it's exciting we're
trying ah so destiny the taken King you
guys are aiming at September 16 15 so
cliff yeah September 15 few short weeks
away and going to be some more live
streams a little more tidbits of
information and as the date approaches
yeah we have one more next Wednesday
that's going to be focused on the
dread-nots checking out that new
destination court of works we've got one
of the designers benoit max gonna be on
the show along with our community
ambassador laced up Lauren it's gonna be
awesome very cool well thank you guys so
much for coming on the state and talking
about the taken king thanks for a very
exciting few weeks since
we see that one come out thanks lemon
all right folks for more on destiny the
taken king be sure to go to gaming die
youtube.com slash gamespot we have in
all the breakdowns of their live streams
and our own super passionate destiny
players bringing you all their expertise
as well we're back here on the live
stage at PAX Prime in just a few minutes
stay with us